would mathematics
exist if people didn't since ancient
times
mankind has hotly debated whether
mathematics was discovered
or invented did we create mathematical
concepts to help us
understand the universe around us or is
math
the native language of the universe
itself
existing whether we find its truths or
not
are numbers polygons and equations truly
real
or merely ethereal representations of
some theoretical
ideal the independent reality of math
has some ancient
advocates the pythagoreans of 5th
century greece
believed numbers were both living
entities and universal principles
they called the number 1 the monad the
generator of
all other numbers and source of all
creation
numbers were active agents in nature
plato argued mathematical concepts were
concrete
and as real as the universe itself
regardless of our knowledge of them
euclid the father of geometry believed
nature itself was the physical
manifestation of mathematical laws
others argue that while numbers may or
may not
exist physically mathematical statements
definitely don't
their truth values are based on rules
that humans created
mathematics is thus an invented logic
exercise
with no existence outside mankind's
conscious thought
a language of abstract relationships
based on patterns discerned by brains
built to use those patterns to invent
useful but
artificial order from chaos one
proponent of this sort of idea
was leopold chronicler a professor of
mathematics in 19th century germany
his belief is summed up in his famous
statement god created the natural
numbers
all else is the work of man during
mathematician david hilbert's lifetime
there was a push to establish
mathematics as a logical construct
gilbert attempted to axiomatize all of
mathematics
as euclid had done with geometry he and
others who attempted this
saw mathematics as a deeply
philosophical game
but a game nonetheless already
one of the fathers of non-euclidean
geometry believed that the existence of
non-euclidean geometry
dealing with the non-flat surfaces of
hyperbolic and elliptical curvatures
proved that euclidean geometry the
long-standing geometry of flat surfaces
was not a universal truth but rather one
outcome
of using one particular set of game
rules
but in 1960 nobel physics laureate
eugene wigner
coined the phrase the unreasonable
effectiveness of mathematics pushing
strongly for the idea
that mathematics is real and discovered
by people
wigner pointed out that many purely
mathematical theories
developed in a vacuum often with no view
towards describing any physical
phenomena
have proven decades or even centuries
later to be the framework necessary
to explain how the universe has been
working all along
for instance the number theory of
british mathematician godfrey hardy
who had boasted that none of his work
would ever be found useful in describing
any phenomena in the real world
helped establish cryptography another
piece of his purely theoretical work
became known as the hardy-weinberg law
in genetics
and won a nobel prize and fibonacci
stumbled upon his famous sequence
while looking at the growth of an
idealized rabbit population
mankind later found the sequence
everywhere in nature
from sunflower seeds and flower petal
arrangements to the structure of a
pineapple
even the branching of bronchi in the
lungs or there's the non-euclidean work
of bernhard riemann in the 1850s
which einstein used in the model for
general relativity a century later
here's an even bigger jump mathematical
not theory
first developed around 1771 to describe
the geometry of position
was used in the late 20th century to
explain how dna
unravels itself during the replication
process
it may even provide key explanations for
string theory
some of the most influential
mathematicians and scientists
of all of human history have chimed in
on the issue as well
often in surprising ways so is
mathematics an invention or a discovery
artificial construct or universal truth
human product
or natural possibly divine creation
these questions are so deep
the debate often becomes spiritual in
nature the answer might depend on the
specific concept being looked at
but it can all feel like a distorted zen
colon
if there's a number of trees in a forest
but no one's there to count them
does that number exist
you